[Music]
all right folks so two stories this week
but I think tie into each other
congresswoman Michele Bachmann appeared
on Jimmy most unfunny host of Weekend
Update Fallon's horrible late-night show
only to be introduced to the song of
lyin now this issue is not about whether
you like michele bachmann or not but the
treatment of a sitting congresswoman on
national television now the drummer of
the in-house band who calls himself
Questlove no way this has to be a
mistake nobody's parents could hate
their child that much oh sorry I meant a
mere Thompson is his name tweeted this
prior to the show's airing i late night
walk on song devotees : you love it when
we start : this next one takes the cake
ask around cuz I ain't tweeting the
title mr. Questlove you can't even spell
title folks the real story here is not
that some renegade artist surprised
everybody with an inappropriate intro
song in that the entertainment industry
as a whole is so vile and so liberal
that at no point did anybody not the
directors not the host not the line
producers not the executive producers no
members of this terrible talentless band
at no point did any of them say hey
maybe would be inappropriate to sandbag
a sitting congresswoman with a vulgar
song like this nowhere during the pitch
meetings during the rehearsals or after
this dunce caps very public tweet did
this conversation take place that's how
much of a liberal echo chamber the
entire entertainment industry is and
this is how much they hate conservatives
there wasn't even that one kid who you
see and every child at movies usually
back with the whole I don't know
you guys this sounds like a bad idea
never happened
see conservatives have more decency than
that you've never seen Miss Michelle
Obama introduced to fat bottomed girl
you've never seen anything like this
happened with Nancy Pelosi
[Music]
need more proof while Miley Cyrus this
week released her new music video
firstly when did putting on a voice
synthesizer and sounding like Jimi five
from short-circuit become considered
singing disassembled dead disassemble
number five and listen when it comes to
Miley Cyrus you can't blame somebody
who's number of hit singles actually
matches that number of their IQ again
the real people are to blame are the
cronies and Patsy's and the
entertainment industry surrounding these
folks all of whom are liberal now
disregarding the fact that the Occupy
protests are pretty much over at this
point Miley Cyrus didn't even have
anybody to inform her that hey most
Americans aren't huge supporters of the
Occupy movement folks the point I really
want to drive home here is that for
every mind-numbing lead um Miley Cyrus
for every Questlove or or Jon Stewart
that you see on TV there are twenty or
thirty people behind the scenes you
don't see pushing an agenda equally as
hard that they feel totally comfortable
because there's no accountability
whatsoever and I see conservatives
complaining but there is something you
can do sure don't watch these shows
don't buy Miley's albums and make sure
your children know why you're not buying
those albums but ultimately you need to
encourage and foster an environment
where your kids
yes conservatives your children should
go to work in the entertainment industry
see conservatives keep focusing on
elections and micro politics that they
forget the grand cultural landscape of
the country we need more conservatives
working in the entertainment industry
both on air and off air we need more
conservatives here on YouTube generating
original online content and far fewer
conservatives playing junior senator or
attending the Tucker Carlson look-alike
conventions culture drives politics and
when conservatives concede that cultural
territory as we've done well you see
what happens politically
[Music]
[Music]